what up yo
i'm dave ruben this is the reuben report
direct message for today july 15
2021. do me a favor subscribe to our
youtube channel
tap the notification bell and see what
happens we've got a q a for you we got
dozens and dozens if not over 100
questions
submitted at reubenreport.locals.com so
we're going to get into a big mix
before we do that though i've got one
story i want to hit on with you
because the administration seems to be
afraid to say the c word not that c
word the other c word communism you
dirty dirty person you
uh yeah the administration will just not
say communism
related to cuba so we're going to talk
about that and then
of course that black lives matter where
black lives matters whatever it is
they are full-on marxist communists
we've known that for quite some time and
they've basically issued a statement
backing the government of cuba and
blaming america
for everything that's happening i will
read you the entire statement a
statement which you will not
see on msnbc or cnn not that you
wise person that you are watch those
ludicrous channels
before i get to any of that though i
want to talk to you guys about
taser you know the world in 2021 can
feel like an unstable and
dangerous place but we can't live in
fear that is for sure
taser is giving people the confidence to
protect themselves by creating
life-saving self-defense
technology taser's line of non-lethal
self-protection devices are small
and lightweight enough to carry with you
or in your glove compartment or
purse yet they're powerful enough to
incapacitate an
attacker guns carry risks for you and
those around you and even pepper spray
can harm you as much as an attacker
and it's often ineffective taser
products are safer and easy to use
they use an electrical charge to
immobilize attackers for up to 30
seconds allowing you time to escape
and send for help taser devices come
loaded with features like laser assisted
targeting and emergency dispatch which
will send
response teams to your gps location upon
firing
more than 237 000 lives have been saved
with the taser network of devices apps
and personnel protect yourself and your
family with taser's line of smart
defense
products unlike solutions that require
extensive training and education taser
products are simple clear
and intuitive to use taser products
empower you they don't confuse you
the people at taser believe that a safer
self-defense is a better self-defense
taser devices are available without a
permit in most u.s states get the taser
purse
plus or taser strike light at taser.com
with promo code ruben say 15
now at taser.com promo code ruben
spelled t-a-s-e-r
dot com promo code rubid restriction
supply seaside for details
and now back to me all right so let's
just talk a little bit about cuba right
up top because the the protests continue
uh there have been rolling blackouts
there because of the government
and shutting off internet and a series
of attacks on citizens and people are
still being brave enough
to be in the streets because you're not
going to believe this guys human beings
want to live freely they want
to live without government coercion they
want to live lives that
are theirs and with a sense of purpose
and not to be told what to do and when
to do it and how to do it and all that
stuff
well for some reason jen saki who is our
white house press
uh press secretary not president
correspondent i don't know what she is
she's just a liar jen zaki who's just
this woman who lies every day she stands
in the white house press room and she
just lies all day well
uh she refuses to blame communism on
this she just won't even say
the c word and before i show you this
video of jen saki i would
uh recommend that if you have any sake
now is your time to drink it here we go
as
the administration tries to figure out
the root causes of migration to the
country
don't we know that the reason people
want to leave cuba
is because they don't like communism
and so as you're trying to figure out
like what the processes
are for these people who want to leave
cuba just
well i'm not sure what your question is
you guys why are people leaving cuba or
what is the process for them getting
here i can explain either of them but
you tell me
yeah do you think that people are
leaving cuba because they don't like
communism
i think we've been pretty clear that we
think people are leaving cuba or not
leaving cuba or protesting in the
streets all as well because
they are opposed to the oppression to
the mismanagement of the government
in the country why won't she say the c
word why won't she just say yes people
are obviously protesting communism
that would be something to say right
like communism
bad capitalism freedom liberty
good why won't she say that and i
tweeted something out this morning that
that caught fire
because where is any democrat that is an
elected official in the united states
saying just flat out communism is bad we
stand against communism
you don't even have to get into the
minutia of what's happening exactly in
cuba at the moment
but the ide ideology of communism that
the government should take over
everything and basically
be in everyone's lives from the media to
business
private enterprise education the entire
thing i mean in many ways it's exactly
what's happening in america right now so
i think you can figure out why the
democrats won't speak out against it
but if this is where we're at right and
it appears to be so where the white
house press secretary
will not say the c word i mean they're
turning communism into voldemort right
i did make a harry potter reference
yesterday again it's against everything
i stand for because i want to keep it
to a sci-fi thing not a wizard thing but
uh
you know in in harry potter they didn't
want to say voldemort's name
and that's what these guys are doing
with communism this is this is
really disturbing but it shouldn't
surprise us because if you think
that this is your parents democratic
party if you think there's any moderate
left in the party there might be
some who are privately moderate but
unless they stand up against the
radicals they don't really exist so show
me
please i mean i would love to see it
show me a democrat who is an elected
official in the united states who will
forcefully
come out against communism and for the
people
of cuba you ain't going to see it from
bernie or aoc
or ilhan omar rashida talib and you
won't even see it from the supposed
moderates you know let's say the chuck
schumer wing of the party ain't going to
see it from any of them
and why you ain't going to see it from
any of them it's because the party has
been completely radicalized
by black lives matter so now let's get
the statement that
black lives matter issued on what's
happening in cuba i'm going to read the
whole thing to you and
as you'll see there's no real
condemnation of the cuban government
it's mostly a condemnation of the united
states they also defend a cop killer
here we go
black lives matter condemns the u.s
federal government's inhumane treatment
of cubans and urges it to immediately
lift the economic embargo this cruel and
inhumane policy
instituted with the explicit intention
of destabilizing country
and undermining cubans right to choose
their own government is at the heart of
cuba's current crisis since 1962 the
united states has forced pain and
suffering on the people of cuba
by cutting off food medicine and
supplies costing the tiny island nation
an estimated 130 billion dollars without
that money it is harder for cuba to
acquire medical equipment needed to
develop its own covid19 vaccines
and equipment for food production this
comes in spite of the country's strong
medical care and history of lending
doctors and nurses to disasters around
the world the people of cuba
are being punished by the u.s government
because
the country has maintained its
commitment to sovereignty and
self-determination
united states leaders have tried to
crush this revolution for decades
instead of international amity respect
and goodwill the u.s government has only
instigated suffering for the country's
11 million people
of which 4 million are black and brown
cuba has historically demonstrated
solidarity with oppressed peoples of
african descent from protecting black
revolutionaries
like asada shakur through granting her
asylum to supporting black
liberation struggles in angola
mozambique guinea bissau
and south africa now we look to
president biden to end the embargo
something barack
obama called for in 2016. this embargo
is a blatant human rights violation and
it must come to an end
now there's no condemnation of the cuban
government itself the communist
dictatorship that the people are
protesting the people on the streets who
want to be free
are not saying anything about a u.s
embargo they want to be free of their
own government they're running around
with american flags
screaming freedom and liberty so what's
beautiful
in a way is what's happening here is
that
the administration can't say anything
bad about communism because they kind of
like it and black lives matter
is now fully exposing itself it used to
be a self-proclaimed marxist
organization then they took that
language off their website
well now they're going all in on
communism right they're not
saying communism is bad and this
government is bad and the u.s maybe made
some mistakes along the way
they're saying this is all the us's
fault and the people
really love the government of cuba and
it would all be okay if it wasn't
for the u.s so all right black lives
matter is a full-on
communist organization and no one in our
administration seems to be willing to
say anything bad about
communism so this is one of those things
i don't mean to be partisan but if you
tell me
that the democrats and the republicans
are
equally bad both sides are just equally
bad and i'm a centrist or something like
that it's like
i don't know can you tell what time it
is like something ain't right here
and i get that the republicans aren't
great but they ain't that
and that thing's pretty freaking
horrible so saki
if you're watching say communism you'll
feel better you'll feel better about it
all right guys let's get to the q a i'm
going to do as many as possible
from your questions submitted at
reubenreport.locals.com oh and by the
way for the first time ever today now
that we have live stream on locals
i am going to jump on live stream a
little bit later and if i didn't get to
your question
today here i will try to get to your
question a little bit later
exclusive for the locals community
because we are here for you
emmy says when is your book coming out
and will we get a special pre-order deal
with signature on it also has he
considered having his own community
for things like that i assume by he you
mean me
uh the pre-order for the book so the
book is coming out
i want to tell you the title and we just
absolutely finalized the cover today
like i saw it like an hour ago but i
won't do it just yet
we will announce the title of the book
we will show you the cover of the book
during my live stream on july 30th right
that's friday july 30th
which will be my last day on the grid
and then as you guys know i go off the
grid
for august um to an undisclosed location
where i will do undisclosed things for
one month
and not have any news or phone or
anything else but on that live stream
we're going to do all sorts of promos
there'll be
signatures we're going to have numbered
copies and we're figuring out a way
we're trying to work through the details
right now i have a meeting about it
right after the show today
to figure out a way that the locals
community will get the first numbered
copies that's what we're trying to
figure out just logistically it's a it's
a little bit of a thing but if i sell
if we sell 10 000 numbered copies on day
one i will sign 10
000 things it will be absolutely my
pleasure
but i'm really excited about this book i
think it's a nice
step it's it's step two it's in maybe in
a trilogy it's it's sort of part two
of after don't burn this book where i
laid out what my ideas are what i think
the right ideas are
this book is well what do you do once
you have those right ideas in the
face of some really awful stuff say an
administration that won't say that
communism
is bad so yeah we're going to figure out
some some giveaways and
i'm going to sign book plates and
they'll be numbered and a whole bunch of
other stuff and yeah
there'll be special stuff for the locals
community
lance says has your thought process
improved
or the way you approach business shifted
since being red-pilled
you know it's an interesting question
because i would say they sort of it it
sort of happened in parallel like as i
started
say becoming a little more libertarian
uh
in my thought process right and talking
to libertarian or even conservative
economists and you know just get let's
get the government out of the way
let's lower taxes let's get rid of
regulation like i was building a
business here right like i have many
employees now
i also have locals now where we have
about 20 employees
and we're hiring right now in miami as
you know and what i kept
as i was learning the ideas a little bit
more right like as the as the red
pilling was happening
it was all becoming very obvious to me
like i would sit down with my
accountants and business managers and
i'd look at
you know how much money we have coming
in and how much money we have going out
and i'm very happy to say that my two
businesses
well well locals is a startup so you
know a startup in an early stage
although we have a ton of good stuff
going startups don't run profitably
yet you know what i mean but we're well
funded and we have a great
there's just so much going on it's just
great i can't even say more for now
but the reuben report business in our
production company is highly profitable
as i always say we treat our guys well
we p we pay everybody's
uh health insurance and their dependence
100
and and i don't do that out of just the
goodness of my heart it's like if you
treat the people that are around you
well
then they will work harder for you and
then hopefully your product is better
and then more people watch or more
people subscribe and all of those things
so that is completely connected to my
thought process the red pilling process
it's like
if you tax the hell out of me which they
do here in los angeles well then i have
less money to say hire people or buy new
equipment or things of that nature so
when we sit down and we're like
you know my guys are like dave we want
to get a new camera or we want to get
this or that like we
try to figure out a way to do it there's
a few things that we we want to do right
now that will probably
uh debut in the fall and like that's a
beautiful thing so i would say
it's not that my thought process
happened and then it all happened it was
happening in conjunction because
i'm very proud to say that this this
operation the reuben report and what
we're doing here and then
the book and locals and everything else
like it's it's all still growing like
you know i say to david almost every day
it's like man we're right back at the
beginning again
and you know we made the right choices
along the way we left the young turks
left our jobs in health insurance
we were then at aura tv for a while we
left there left our jobs in health
insurance we went on patreon
i didn't like what was happening on
patreon we left that built what became
the beginnings of locals and went fully
independent then turned locals into a
tech company and raised millions of
dollars like
these these are all like the ideas that
i care about without saying to the
government help me help me
so i would say these things happen in
parallel thanks for the question lance
leia says freedom fest next week are you
still speaking and are you willing to do
a locals meet up i'm from california and
i will be there yes
i will be at freedom fest next week i
know ayan hersey ali will be there and
michael shermer will be there
and a bunch of other friends of mine
will be there and it's a it's a big
libertarian-esque conference we're going
to talk all about freedom and big tech
and what some of the solutions are
i will be giving a main stage speech at
11
am 11 to 11 30 on thursday july 22nd
then i'm doing another panel and yeah
maybe we can figure out a locals meet up
or i'll just grab a drink with some of
you guys
obviously i'm not posting that publicly
so you got to join us at
reubenreport.locals.com and i hope
to see you there storm says i try to buy
locally when i can but some of the best
places virtue signals so bad i question
my purchase at times
as a consumer when do you put your foot
down and when do you grit and bear it
this is a great question i think we're
all kind of struggling with this right
like
so i still have amazon am i thrilled
with amazon of course i'm not thrilled
with amazon they blew up the
the parlor servers they're they're so
ubiquitous and in
every part of our life now like what we
buy and what we watch and the servers
that put websites up and everything else
that it's if they're becoming too big
right like so i i don't begrudge them
like i don't begrudge jeff bezos for
building an amazing product it's
actually pretty amazing and as a guy
that's in the tech world now i know how
hard it is
i have at least an inkling of how hard
it is so i don't begrudge him that but
at some point
you know to say that you're for small
government well it's because you're
against
giant power over us so i would apply
that same principle to these businesses
that they have become so big like what's
what feels more powerful to you
what has more to do with your day-to-day
life is it the us government or is it
big tech is it amazon and everything
else right
like if the government just you know got
out of your life you'd probably be
pretty happy if big tech
got rid of everything all your services
you'd be you'd be freaking out now it
might ultimately be
be good because we could rebuild some
smaller things perhaps but i think you
see my point
so i try as much as possible to buy
locally when i can
i try not to buy everything on amazon i
know it's easy
you know what i mean like i know it's
easy you run out of paper towels and you
can just
amazon and it's there the next day i try
to go to stores you know also this last
year it just completely made the
problem worse because everyone started
ordering everything and we were going
out less and
everything else um but i do try like
you know if i try to like if i see a kid
with a lemonade stand i try to buy the
freaking lemonade although i never have
cash on me anymore which is a problem
so if you're a lemonade stand kid uh you
got to start accepting you got to get
like a stripe thing or something just so
we can scan a credit card or something
that's a little tip for you kids out
there
um but i think you got it you got to try
as much as you can but don't don't feel
guilty about it because we're all trying
you know it's like
i get it like disney sucks and has
ruined so many of the things that we all
love
i mean you know my feelings on what
they've done to star wars but it's like
i get it if you're a parent
and you know your kids want access to
the disney movies and you pay the money
for that
hopefully you're not getting them
brainwashed by everything else but we
all
i think that's your point about grit and
barrett it's like when do you just say
no
enough is enough and when do you just
you know oh you know
michael's looking at me like he likes
bad batch you like bad batch okay you
like
i watched the first one then i kind of
fell asleep that was it but like i get
it he doesn't love disney
but he's like you know we're all playing
the game and maybe you get your account
from
your cousin i don't know what you're
doing over there uh danielle
says how can locals help improve the
conservative ground game the democrats
are great at organizing and getting
tangible results
republicans still struggle with that
would be great to have an action
component in locals
linking your community with
organizations and other resources
so we've been thinking about something
like this again you know we've really
only had this company for two years and
and trust me what we've built
i was telling you guys we we own all of
the tech we own all of the code
the live streaming we built ourselves
like you know we're doing something
really special here
and i want to announce things that i
can't quite tell you right now
but good things are happening but yes
the next part of that is i want
you know the reason i love the name
locals is the idea was oh i'm building
my locals community i'm building my
digital home that's what we've got
over there so if youtube literally if
youtube twitter facebook if the whole
if the whole crew of them kicked me off
tomorrow if my accounts all blew up
right now if this live stream just ended
right now
i still have a thriving business because
of locals i still have an ability to
live stream i still have an ability to
get push notifications out to you guys
and everything else
so that's why i love the idea of locals
but yes the next part of that
is i want people to be able to link to
local businesses that they can
support nonprofits that they're
interested in to be able i want to
create some sort of
actually gets to an earlier question
like a smaller amazon marketplace
where it's like i want people that are
in my community uh to be promoting their
own products which by the way is
happening in
in the community and we know that people
have bought artwork and people have
bought
spices and all kind of coffee and all
kinds of stuff
so i love that like i think we've gone
from
too big to fail to too big to succeed
and it's like let's figure out ways to
i want to work with more nonprofits we
actually just started doing that so
prageru is now
on uh locals and a couple others and
it's like we will figure out ways to fix
this like i just believe in human
ingenuity i believe in the human mind
like we've been around for a long time
millennia human beings and we've we've
survived bad things before and we will
survive the bad things that are
happening right now
but it starts with us all getting
involved one way or another uh tj
says that now that larry elder has
thrown his hat into the recall ring do
you think he can attract younger black
voters
because they will respect his seniority
and sense of authority
or do you think his age and traditional
values could work against him
uh that's a great question i should tell
you that i will be
interviewing my good buddy larry elder
we're doing it in studio
on monday and then i believe we're
posting it on on tuesday if i'm not
mistaken
um so i can't wait to sit down with or i
guess we're going to post that on
wednesday we got a couple things
cooking already but i can't wait to sit
down with larry i will ask him that very
question i mean look larry
is a fact machine larry as i said
yesterday he falls a little bit more
on i would say the libertarian side of
the conservative movement which that's a
little bit more where i am
i don't think larry cares about
something like gay marriage i don't
think larry really cares what you smoke
in the privacy of your own
bedroom i know that larry wants the
economy open i know that he wants
critical race theory out of
schools i know that he doesn't want to
just throw money at
everything right like that's the that's
the real libertarian jolt
that california needs that you know even
right now is gavin newsom there's
commercials every two seconds every time
i open up a youtube video it's gavin
newsom is doing so great california's
roaring back
and it's like with tax breaks and tax
cuts and it's like
oh what a nice man gavin newsom giving
us the
money that we earn that he stole from us
in the first place
it's like it's so funny if you think
about how the democrats think
it's like they reward us with tax breaks
and tax credits and all that
well okay how about you just lower taxes
in the first place how about just take
less like if you've got the money
and i get it they don't really have the
money it's and it's federal bailouts and
they just print money endlessly
but larry i think has absolutely all the
right ideas
to directly answer your question though
about say younger black people
i mean i do think that there has been a
huge awakening within i hate the phrase
community but the black community
related to what's going on with the
democrats we know that trump's support
for uh trump's black support was doubled
from
2016 to 2018 something like four percent
to about nine percent now that's not
huge i get it it's not huge
but if something doubles and doubles a
doubles and doubles well now we got some
scaling like something interesting is
going on here
um so we know that we also know that
trump did very well uh
you know with the hispanic community uh
we also know that younger black people
aren't as uh stuck and brainwashed
which i would say younger white people
aren't and younger hispanic people
aren't you're not going to believe this
i'm starting to think that people
despite their skin color are all kind of
the same they all kind of want the same
things
so i hope that it'll work so when you
say traditional values i don't know
exactly
what you mean by that but i would say
that i think that larry's got the right
idea set and i hope he's
really really willing to fight and and
just
imagine imagine a debate if if larry can
get
in there imagine a debate between larry
elder fact
machine who's got a good sense of humor
and is a good man and
fun and smiley and happy uh against
evil american psycho gavin newsom like i
would just
i will pay money to see it anyway larry
will be in here right in this very room
uh next week and then i told him uh you
know for the rest of july i'm willing to
travel with them and fundraise do
whatever i'm off for august but happy to
pick it up
in september and help them in any way
that i can uh amy says i just watched
the lara
logan episode on big tech in which you
are interviewed as you were talking
about locals i wondered as it went from
idea to fruition what was it that you
experienced personally and emotionally
uh so for those of you that haven't seen
it i did uh part of a documentary with
lara logan that's on fox nation
and lara is just she's an actual
journalist what a refreshing statement
that is to make that there's someone out
there
that actually cares about truth and is
going you know to the places this is a
woman who is in
tahrir square in egypt some pretty
horrible things happen to her there she
goes out in the field she reports on
antifa
she reports on what's happening in the
war on drugs all sorts of stuff and i
was thrilled that she came here
her team they interviewed me for about
five hours it was really great and we
talked all about big tech
so your question is um on the local side
as it went from idea to fruition
what was it that you experienced
personally emotionally well first off i
had no
you know like i just had this idea like
let's just build small communities if we
build it for me
like the first idea was not that we were
building a giant company it really was
like well
if i get kicked off all of these places
like i want my stuff
to be accessible and i want to be able
to make some money and i want to be able
to communicate with my audience let's
build it
and it didn't seem like rocket science
to me it was it was a little tricky to
build
but we built it and then once it started
working for us
i was like man we should spawn this off
to other people like this is what every
creator
it doesn't matter if you're a political
creator if you're a sports guy or a
video gamer or an unboxer
or a knitter whether you're a lefty or a
righty
none of that matters like let's just
give the tools so that somebody can have
a home
a home online i think that's what we all
want i actually think i don't want to
give too much away but i think that
a next version of locals as we continue
to reiterate and
you know you pivot into different things
like we could start making locals
communities for everybody like what
facebook was supposed to be instead of
just this giant
you know mismatch of stuff that makes
everyone angry and hate people they used
to like and everything else
that if you just had a home that was
yours and then you figure out who do you
want to be in a
sort of wider community with but i would
say personally emotionally it was it's
been way more work like i
you know most of my days now are are
dealing with locals
related stuff i'm not running i'm not
the ceo of the company
but i you know i'm on virtually all of
the meetings i'm onboarding people i'm
i'm selling the company i'm the main pr
guy
um and then i'm involved in some of the
technical decisions and when we're going
to lay things out
and then the fundraising which was like
months and months and months of
hours a day and traveling and all that
stuff but i got to say i love it i love
it like
it's one of the coolest things i think
you could do as an adult to like
be part of building something that a
that you think is important
and that is vital and good and it's it's
good for you
and hopefully good for the world and you
know
for the first year or so i didn't take
any money from locals i get a
couple thousand bucks a month now like a
very small salary um
just for my time basically but like
could there be a huge financial reward
at the end
of course there could be but like that's
not really what i'm doing it for like
it's actually
fun to do so i would say i'd say it's
been very validating like it's like oh
i saw you know it's sort of like it's
very in line i would say with my
political evolution like i was like
years ago i was like guys there's
something wrong with the left they're
all bananas we're not all nazis
can we do something about this and then
like the world kind of caught up to that
um and i think that's sort of what's
happening with locals like everyone knew
there was a problem with big tech and a
couple years ago i was like oh i guess i
should solve the problem like i'm a guy
someone should solve the problem like
why don't i do it i'm a guy like me
right that's the
famous homer simpson line uh ben says
where is the outrage about the political
prisoners that have been detained are
and are in solidarity as the result of
january 6
juxtaposed with the blm antifa
participants who have all had their
charges dropped greatly
reduced and are out on bail pending
their constantly to protect
constitutionally protected rights this
is a great question so i haven't done
much on this and it's a little
unclear how to get all of the
information on this but it sounds like
there are many people i don't know how
many
that were arrested on one six on january
6th
at the capitol either for violent acts
or they were there or trespassing or
whatever the charges are and they
haven't had charges fully brought
against them and some of them have
been in solitary confinement and a whole
bunch of other stuff and of course the
mainstream media isn't
talking about it now look a hundred
percent if you violently broke into a
building if you tacked in a police
officer
etcetera etcetera then we are a nation
of laws as i always say and you have to
apply those laws fairly your point is we
don't apply those laws fairly right
because we've got these people that are
now charged or or not charged but are
incarcerated
some version of that and then we know
that there are hundreds if not thousands
of blm and antifa people
who attack federal court buildings in
portland and burn down buildings and
destroy kenosha
and i can go through all the cities that
you know and create chop
a zone where you know it's a lawless mad
max style zone
in seattle and it's like well that's
illegal
was anyone arrested for any of that
stuff should the
politicians who allowed it to happen
like ted wheeler the ridiculous
mayor in portland should he be arrested
because he's allowing illegal things to
happen
in his city i mean i think there's a lot
of questions about that like these das
in these cities
los angeles san francisco et cetera if
you just say we're not going to
prosecute certain crime trespassing
criminal theft whatever it is whatever
the crime is we just say we're not going
to prosecute these things in new york
city where the new d.a doesn't want to
prosecute if you jump the turnstile to
get on the subway i don't know i think
it's about 250 275
you swipe your thing well you're
basically saying hey go be a criminal
go be a criminal well i have to believe
that that's against their oath of office
or their their the duty that they signed
up for right
um so i think we're gonna have to get
some of this stuff in the courts and
uh and hopefully we'll find out more
about some of these people that are
being held
uh tom says with cuba so prevalent in
the news right now what would you do as
president that biden isn't doing to
stand up for the freedom lovers of cuba
well first off
it's directly related to how i started
today you say this is about communism
because that is the truth
these people are not out there screaming
that they're not getting enough vaccines
that is
simply not what's happening that is the
narrative that is being spun
by our ridiculous corporate media and by
our administration
but i would get up there and have a
little bit of
moral clarity you don't have to have a
ton of it but
they they seem to have none of it biden
should be up there saying
people yearn to be free we know that
communism
over the last hundred years every single
place that communism
has been tested has been an affront to
human dignity
that has been an experiment where lots
of people get killed
because guess what not every person
wants to just be a cog in a much bit
much bigger system right we could he
could make a pro-capitalist
argument right he could actually read
that blm statement and explain why the
us has done what it's done with
sanctions
and why people yearn to be free and the
rest of it and he could even say you
know maybe we did make some mistakes
over the years and i know obama wanted
to talk about sanctions and maybe
there's a way to do less with
sanctions so that the economy there
frees up a little bit like there's all
sorts of things you could do
but i think it it starts with
acknowledging reality as it
is which is that the people there
want to be free the problem is the
democrats
have are being the inmates are running
the asylum
in the democratic party right now and if
biden was to
forcefully come out against communism
what that what the base would take that
as
means you're against socialism right
because socialism is just communism done
slightly more legally right they're
going to use the system
as it is until they get the communist
takeover and then they just change the
system altogether but the idea
of the centralized state controls
everything that's the
that's the link really between socialism
and communism okay
so he knows that if he really comes out
forcefully against communism that the
base which is now a bunch of socialists
including the people in his own party
aoc talib omar etc
that they will turn on him so they've
they've created just an
a really really evil monster
and they don't know how to control that
monster they've got frankenstein's
monster
on their hands and good luck to you guys
jamie says what are your thoughts
regarding andrew yang lately i saw a
meme where he is portrayed as the voice
of reason between
the arguing left and right so you know
yang of course ran for president
basically polled at zero the entire time
i saw a lot of people sort of
in my circles that were like oh he's not
obsessed with identity politics he seems
like he has some new ideas
so they were sort of publicly supporting
him look i had him on the show
i liked chatting with the guy and i
think he did have some of the right
ideas
that being said you know a couple weeks
before the new york city mayoral
election because he also ran in that and
and did extremely poorly in that as well
he was interviewed by the new york times
and that that woman we've shown a couple
clips of her my i think it's maya gay
right maya gay or marigay
marigay i think um she basically said
that i'm a white supremacist and that he
did my show and he didn't push back at
all like he basically completely threw
me under the bus and he was like
he was like oh i wouldn't have to do
shows like that if you guys meaning you
lefties would invite me on more shows
so i'm not very impressed with yang like
i'm
i'm just not i don't think he's a bad
dude i think he's a decent human being
he likes basketball he smiles every now
and again he's not
a generic politician
but ultimately it's like you you ran a
campaign that had no support you then
became a cnn
contributor then you ran for new york
city mayor
no support it's like if you're so great
and you're such an innovator and you
think so differently about things like
go accomplish something in in the
private sector now like show us
how good you are things uh you know he
also then went to
georgia and he was really campaigning
for the democrats there so it's like you
ran for president you failed
then you went to georgia you've never
lived in georgia as far as i know or you
certainly didn't live in georgia at the
time
like why are you obsessed with politics
all these people that like you're just
chasing around politics all the time
don't don't really impress me
uh tina says uh you have so much going
on yet you seem happy and not
overwhelmed how do you do it all
and not go bananas um i would say i'm
pretty
happy actually like i i keep telling
people say to me how you doing i'm like
well despite the revolution i'm doing
all right like
i feel pretty good about life like david
and i are
happy it's the summer like i always
enjoy this time of year
it was my birthday a couple weeks ago
it's david's birthday on on monday
my businesses are good my my employees
are good like
we're taking uh this off the grid thing
so we're going away for
for a little bit and i'm gonna have no
phone for a freaking month i think
that's a big piece of it like i don't
let this
this endless machine of lunacy
i don't let it like infect every part of
my life i think there was a time that i
did you know when i
first started doing all this and when
the show started blowing up and when i
when i did that why i left the left
video
and i started getting so much hate i
mean you guys all know the story like i
developed
an autoimmune disease i developed
alopecia areata i lost about 40 percent
of my hair i'd wake up in the morning
and
just clumps of hair in my hand i went on
experiment experimental medication it
was
absolutely horrible but since then i've
started
to just deal with stress better i start
the day every day i have a little water
with lemon i have my coffee
i try to do cardio i try to do about an
hour of cardio this morning i did an
hour and a half of cardio you know what
i did this morning i started my morning
i woke up
i'm an early riser so i woke up at about
7 a.m i
went on youtube and i usually watch old
basketball games or something
they had the full 1985 transformers
movie not the michael bay
transformers that are absolutely
horrible the original cartoon movie
after two seasons of the cartoon
transformers more than meets the eye
remember those guys
and and it's just an incredible movie
orson welles plays unicron
it's his last thing that he ever did
before he died just incredible
uh the uh leonard nimoy is the voice of
galvatron like just some really like
great stuff in there robert stack is the
voice of uh not radimus prime
robert stack transformers movie uh not
uh prime uh ah it's killing me
robert stack transformers movie who did
he play ultra magnus
i got that before he googled it ultra
magnets there you go anyway so i did i
was like i'm watching this thing it
ended up being about an hour and 40
minutes so i did cardio the entire time
so i i we try to eat right you know i
post a lot of pictures
on the locals community like i love good
food
um like playing with the dog i don't
know and i
and i will say something else actually
which is that you know you guys know
that
you know years ago i was saying that i
was an atheist and i think
as i've as i've moved away from that and
i would say
that i'm a believer and i've talked
about it a bunch and i make a belief
argument and dover in this book and i
i've talked about that jordan peterson
clip when he talks about belief that you
know truth for truth sake
and saying the truth is the ultimate
expression of
uh faith in a way right you're taking
the leap of faith by saying
hey if i say the truth the best possible
thing will happen it doesn't mean that
all good things will happen
like that's a type of faith that i
believe in and i think that that has
also made me
not crazy like all for all the craziness
right now it feels like the country is
becoming
like we're we're succumbing to communism
and marxism and all these horrible ideas
and suddenly
being racist is the new not being racist
and like all of these horrible things
are happening but like i think
i just believe i believe that
my ancestors had it worse than i did
much worse than i did and that humans go
through
times of really terrible stuff and i
think if we can just wake up
enough people we won't be crazy and and
or we won't lose it we won't lose it
and i that gives me great comfort that
really does give me great comfort so
that
you know keeps a smile on my face and uh
we're in the middle of re-watching
curvier enthusiasm so he started
season six last night you know i try not
to look at my phone after like 8 p.m or
so
i do sometimes but i try i definitely
don't tweet on the weekends and actually
really
and i'm not saying this as a sales job
but but the community that we've created
on locals i open up that app
and it's like good people sharing their
ideas and personal lives and
and pictures of sporting events and and
food and and what they're listening to
and everything else and it's like
that's my off-ramp for all the craziness
um so
you know and it's not everything that's
the point if you don't believe
that politics is everything you can find
happiness right now like if you're
struggling with something and we all
struggle with different things
i'm not saying i got no issues like i've
got some some family stuff
you know like we've all got stuff right
like we've all got stuff
but i think if you can keep a little
perspective people have been through
bad stuff before and that politics is
not everything and that if you work to
make sure that the
the bad people in politics can't make
every decision for you that can infringe
on every part of your life
then i think you'll be happier and uh
you know having some
some decent friends and stuff like that
guys part two of my interview with kevin
mccarthy
uh gop minority leader of the house is
up on youtube right now the full episode
is up early and ad
free at ruben report.locals.com and we
are doing a round table tomorrow i know
it's been a little while since we did
one because of my travels
rogan o'hanley will be on lawyer ron
coleman
and ali stuckey from blaze tv
and uh as this conversation went today
i've now got 8 000 locals meetings so
oh and one book meeting so i got stuff
to do i hope you have stuff to do that
that gives you a sense of purpose and
happiness and joy
have a good day i will see you tomorrow